and the workshop the boot camp and we
are really honored to have peter bickle
here
to give this talk so peter is a
professor of statistics here at uc
berkeley so we're really glad that he's
here i specifically i'm very glad that
he's here and he's going to tell us
about david blackwell thank you thank
you
well let's thank you for inviting me
it's
it's always a pleasure to talk about
david
um
i intend to talk a little bit about
david as a person since i knew him
actually in various ways and then i want
to talk a bit about
the paper
uh that in fact i gather is sort of
at the base of much of the work of this
boot camp the vector minimax there
and um
but we'll get to that so let me start by
the
obvious picture of i
it's one that i see hasn't been shown
yet
but um it's
it's it's fairly characteristic i mean
he's he's smiling and and that's that
was general characteristic of his um
he liked life
all right so first of all let me also
give
some references i think that you've got
gotten many more
from from um
from other talks
but uh so the photos the credit of
george bergman is a faculty member in
mathematics here
and there are at least a couple of
papers that i'm more familiar with or
books really one called mathematical
people which has a
long interview with david
and another one an earlier one a
conversation with david blackwell in
1986
in statistical science and both are
really quite revealing
well let me here here are some
highlights very
quickly
summarized of his career
uh i see that i made a mistake or
there's at least a mistake was made for
me that his he didn't live to like 2020.
he lived to 2010.
and
he started out as you've heard already
uh educated university of illinois
his talents were recognized quite early
uh he was his thesis advisor was joe
dube who's
rather well known in statistical
probabilistic circles
and dupe took him with him to the
princeton institute and study as uh
keshe mentioned
um
and then
after that he went to howard
and finally ended up working
now
it's true that he was as
said the right person at the right time
but it's also true that he did have
some difficulties
so uh in illinois he he went to one of
three high schools uh one of which was
all black one which was all white and
one which was mixed he was able to go to
the mixed school his teachers recognized
his talents early i hadn't heard
before bin's
note that he was already recognized
for his brilliance but that's not
surprising really
but he went to illinois originally
planning to be a teacher of mathematics
a high school teacher
but uh
there again his talent was recognized he
got to his bachelor's quickly uh he
think he was encouraged to go on
to the phd by paul halmosh who some of
you may have heard of and another guy
warren ambrose both who were students of
dubs
and he finished his phd quickly uh dub
then uh
brought him with him as a rosenwald
fellow to the princeton institute where
everything went well at the institute
but um
the math department in fine hall
refused to grant him the privileges
which were usually given to to uh
other
rosenwald fellows at the institute
uh however
he survived that
and uh and he survived it because
of this general attitude to life and
research which i think i would like to
mention early
and then
i have
always encapsulated as david liked
always thought that the cup was half
full rather than half empty he was a
very very positive person
and and i mean very kind as others have
heard but he also just
took life as it as it went and in the
end he did
uh he was rewarded with the honors that
that was due but it took quite a while
uh he made contributions in many things
not only in approachability
but uh in renewal theory
in information theory
in logic actually
uh towards the end
uh of course in statistics the raw
blackwell theorem uh
but actually other even more significant
contributions
and as i said he had many honors
okay my contacts with him
i started out in 1959 or 60
as a student in his class in information
theory which was a wonderful class
uh and he did indeed give wonderful
clear lectures as you've heard mentioned
several times
but it compensated for a book i didn't
like
by jack wolfowitz
which was called coding theorems and
information theory and how does the
subtitle i somehow recall information
theory for mathematicians
to show that you know how pure it was
but i just now in retrospect i think
david may have chosen it because it
enabled him to show his view
which was quite different
in any case
um
okay so that was the start
and then
i i didn't do my phd with him but i will
tell you a story which is quite relevant
to the to the paper i'm going to talk
about
uh but
um
he uh you know i got my phd i became an
assistant professor at berkeley
and uh
then you know i talked to david and at
some point
i was teaching a graduate course in
statistical theory
and i came on a problem on something in
his book
blackwell and gershwick
and something in eric damon's books
book on testing hypotheses and by or
assassination in any case i noticed
something that might be interesting and
i went up to him and i talked to him for
about an hour and we concluded that we
understood what was going on and then he
said go write it up
so
i think it was a gift to a young
assistant professor but
in any case the paper appeared and i let
me tell you about it very very briefly
because that's all it deserves it's
called a note on bayes estimates
and there's a classic result which
started this all
which is the following which i think
many of you probably know that if x and
y are such that
both x squared and y squared have finite
second moments
and the conditional expectation of y
given x is x and the conditional
expectation of x given y is y
then x equals y with probability one
that's the only way you can have that
and
that actually can be translated in both
provisional statistics in probability
it's translated as a forward and
backward martingale is constant
and in statistics and that's where i
started is if a bayes estimate with
respect to quadratic loss is unbiased
its bay's risk is zero
and that's what this paper is about and
what
our paper was simply generalization
to unbiased and based with respect to
general convex losses
in particular uh
the
lp losses
um
and it turns out that for p strictly
bigger than one it generalizes
straightforwardly for p equals one it's
actually not true unless
one
puts the conditional
that's because the median is not unique
uh the loss is not strictly convex
okay
now to my main topic and actually that's
the reason that i in fact after some
hesitation agreed
to speak
because uh you know i've often have
various things reminiscences of
david in various places and
didn't see it necessary to to do that
again but
it turns out this paper has some
significance for me the
analog of the minimax theorem for vector
payoffs and the significance is that
when i was a graduate student
before i decided to work with eric
layman
i went around shopping for a thesis i
didn't want didn't have my own idea for
a thesis and i went around dropping
prosthesis and in particular i went to
david and david
showed me this paper
and said well there are a couple of
conjectures in here that you might be
interested in i looked at it
unfortunately i had no idea what the von
neumann theorem was much less
much less the
effector analog i got a bit frightened
and also uh i guess
there were other things i knew better so
i
i well i worked with eric which was
wonderful too
okay
so
but i decided of course having then why
not finally find out what that paper is
about
and so i read it and it's really a
delightful paper and and and
very interesting
okay so
it's ba the first step is that it's a
dynamic formulation it can be viewed as
one neumann min max theory
so the von neumann theorem is a one-shot
deal
right you have a randomized strategy
your gains or expectations
well david simply change that into
you can have an infinite number of plays
f1 fn
and then you look at the average
game and in the von neumann theorem
right the gain let's see i'm not sure i
get to yeah there's a payoff matrix of
course mij this is all finite david
loved fine i think he was not too happy
with
with great abstraction um
uh so the
dynamics is if you play an arbitrary
number of times n tending to infinity
you have strategies
f1 g1 for the two players
the payoffs are x1 through xn
right
um according to the matrix depending
upon what you play simple strategies of
players
or
random
the randomized strategies give you each
time
and then you have the payoff at time
time
k
and you have can use probabilities
as you please and in fact
i should say they can be
nothing says that they're
this suggests that they're fixed for all
time no they can depend on they can be
markovian in fact you want them to be
markov
all right so then you identify the von
neumann theorem
as in this way there exists a value v
right and a strategy fk which is the
same you play the same thing each time f
star
for one such that the average tends to v
no matter what strategy you use
and vice versa
and
you know
to approach in some sense from above and
from below right
um
okay
so what's the generalization he
considers
he considers vector payoffs right mij
is in
rk
and you have a definition which rocket
gave earlier given a close set s in rk
and s is approachable
if and only if there exists a strategy f
star
for player 1
such that the distance between the
average and the set s
tends to zero
no matter what strategy two plays right
so there's no no no max mid anymore but
simply no strategy would put
with two plays and but you still want to
win right
which is get to s
s is excludable if and only if there
exists a g star and a positive d
such that basically you're kept away
the distance d
from
s
okay
so
there is he has a more general theorem
but the theorem which i believe rakish
quoted and which i think is a
special support you have general closed
convicts that's by the way
neither closure nor boundedness
are relevant i mean they both are
without loss to get around
um
and the theorem he says is if s is
convex it is always either approachable
or excluded
um
as you see it extends to general but not
all sets and that's a bit of a
reason for my comment when when rakesh
put down his
initial statements that
it's not true
in general there's a closed set
which is neither approachable nor
excludable in this sense
there's a weaker sense in which every
set is explo uh
approach
okay
all right first obvious remark is it's
enough to consider approachability and
suitability for player one
because you can just switch
from m to m transpose
for player two
uh and of course intuitively f1 star f2
etc are not independent
but
what you
what it turns out all you need to do for
this purpose
is
to basically have the law
of the average gain at time n plus one
given the past gains
to be to depend only on that on the
average gain given n plus one and then
the same thing with the strategy
so in some sense
it's markovian and markovian given
the average gain previously
okay
here is i think the first
key observation
which
which i haven't seen anywhere else
he makes an identification a
representation
of mixed strategies
as follows
suppose that you have suppose at p the
vector oops what happens
vector p is a strategy for one and the
vector q is a strategy for two okay the
probabilities on one through r and one
through s
the reward r of p
is the set of all possible vector
payoffs
that can occur
if one plays p
right so it's it's it's the set p
transpose mq where q varies over the
simplex
and similarly there's r that's rfp
obviously it's a convex polyhedron
because it's a convex mixture of finite
number of points
and similarly you have t of q which is
the same thing but for player two
and clearly r of p
corresponds in a is a is a way of coding
all q
for every p
and t of q is a way of coding all q for
every p
okay
all right so there's an obvious
alternative representation of the game
one picks rfp two picks cq and the
payoff is p transpose mq
okay
all right
now i'm going to i think give a
probably not new proof of the von
neumann theorem
but a proof of the neumann theorem using
simply this idea of black holes
okay so notice that in one dimension
r of p is simply a set of intervals
right that's
they're all each of the rfps is convex
so you have intervals a fp b of p
and now you can turn these at the half
rays right because it it doesn't matter
as far as
um you know this these correspond to
to um the cubes right
b and p is a payoff from sum q
right it's a little bit confusing
but you can make them into half rays
without any loss
minus infinity to b of p
right
which is the highest payoff that q can
get
right
and similarly
the same for
the q intervals t of q but there you
move it the other way d of 2 infinity
now notice that
r of p and t of q is not empty
for all p and q right because in
particular
if it's q that's player two is playing
the the one corresponding to p
the point corresponding to p is the
total payoff
right
so
furthermore notice that if you make this
identification you have an ordering
if b of p1 is bigger than or equal to p
of p2 our tilt of p1 contains our tilt
of p2 that's the one where you extend
to the end
and the same with d
and now simply let
b star
with the argument over p
to p
and q star the r of max over q
and
these star and queues are assumed by
compactness
of the simplexes
and
of course our p star just section two t
of q star is not empty
in fact it's one point
which is
the value
and those are the those are the
strategies there may be more than one
pair of optimal strategies but we know
that's always the case so there's the
proof
right so it doesn't require hyperplanes
or any of that stuff
and the brilliance of it is that you
translate this
high dimensional problem into a one
dimensional problem
we can use the order of the line which
of course we can't use in general
okay
so i don't know if that's one of the
five proofs may well be
rockers told me that there are at least
five blues
well five
well those authors would inject because
of the appeal to compactness oh come on
what do you mean
i'm just talking about the old-fashioned
1928.1
okay
would you mind straight can you go back
two slides where you defined were you
before the proof where you defined
the rs
i think
previous one before that okay um
so
at the end there where you say
our
r
can be identified with the set of all
cubes
i see right that's the way it's called
i mean again yeah repeats yeah yeah
that's it
okay there we go all right
all right
now we go to context s and now we've got
vector case
[Music]
all right
the claim is that the
sufficient condition for approachability
is that the intersection of every one
of the t of cubes
with s
is
why is that well remember that both tf2
and s
are closed convex sets
so if they don't intersect
you can draw a hyperplane between them
and intuitively sort of clear
that if they don't intersect
for some q
you just two will use that q
because no matter what p
comes in
it's going to be in t of q
and not to stay away from the center
all right that's here's actually more
somewhat form more formal
uh statement of what i just said if t of
q zero under section s is empty and two
uses every time from zero
of course it's he gets he doesn't get q0
each time he gets a pure strategy a pure
result each time but
um
this is obviously true
x n bar minus the conditional expected
the average of the conditional
expectations
of the output given whatever
uh one place
right because q plus q zero always
uh
is going to
this it belongs to tf20
right that average belongs to
zero
because q0 is played every time
um
okay
now
the other way is not so easy
uh and that's
suppose that t of 2 0 is not equal to
the empty set for all q should be q zero
should be q
okay
then i won't go through the details but
you look at the ordinary von neumann
theorem the one dimensional one
applied to the gains
x minus y of x mij who's y of x
y of x is the closest point
to x
yes
so it's again you'll see a picture very
similar to the picture that rakesh had
in his lecture um
then by the ordinary neumann theorem
you can argue that there exists a piece
such an rfp is separated from x by hard
to play
and i'll show you the picture i hope
oh i'm sorry that's not the picture yes
not yet
okay so so so strategy is actually the
following
you
use
x and bar the average up to time n
to choose
what
randomized distribution we'll use
next time
and if x n bar
belongs to s already it doesn't matter
what you do
but if x n bar is not in s
you find y of x n bar closest to x n bar
in s right the closest point and then
you proceed according to exactly the
picture for the rocket group and here it
is
not not quite as negative
but it's the same picture right
here is s
here is t of q
here's x n bar
here's the foot of the perpendicular
here's y of x
right
here's
um
everything is on
one side
and basically
what you go for is
you go to the t of q intersection s
closest to y of x and bar
which is on
the first one you hit i don't know
that that corresponds to a p right
because t of q is just the set of all
p's
all right and here's the heuristic and
now again this this comes back to
rakash's a very nice presentation
if x does not belong to s and y of x is
the closest point
hyperplane
then
here's the hyperplane like the equation
of the hyperplane y minus x eta equals y
minus xy because y is on the hyperplane
y minus x is the perpendicular
and all eight on eight of on h or on the
other side x you have
this inequality
finds
that side of the hyperplane
and then you have a stop martingale type
problem yes as
rockets mentioned
you you it's approachable
no matter what q is used
each time by uh two
if u n is y of x n bar minus x and bar
right
then the conditional expectation of u n
x n plus one given x one x n is bigger
than or equal to u n y of x and bar
right
that's simply stating exactly the fact
that the thing is on the other side
they're doing one side of the hyperplane
and the other one's on the other side
and then you use the fact that of course
for any queue t of q intersection s is
not empty
and then
this i'm not following david's argument
uh
if
um you define delta n
to be the square distance between y of x
and bar and x and and
x and bar
then you don't have quite a semi-martin
gale
you have a little bit extra but not much
right here's the same martingale
property plus
c over n squared you just make the
computation
but that's always the case
and from that you can deduce the delta
instructions almost between zero by this
theorem that
that
so
there's some interesting consequences
which i'll just mention again these are
things that david noted
rfp is always approachable
that's always an approachable convex set
because
rfp intersection tf2 is not empty for
all keys obviously again
uh
and then there's a connection with with
one neumann games
s convex is approachable if and only if
the value of a
certain scalar gain
is bigger than or equal to
the minimum of us
yes
capital s that's again this
related to this hyperplane property
um
oh and the
scalar game maybe i should clarify u m
means it's the inner product
between u and n m if you remember is a
vector u is a vector so so that's the
scale
what is that
is there and there is i'm sorry m m is
the payoff matrix but the elements of
the payoff matrix are vectors
okay
all right
i think i'm going to end quite hard
all right
which i agree
um
okay
all right so david has his conjecture in
this
paper of his
and the conjecture was that oh i'm sorry
he gives an example which i will not
give you i refer you to the paper of a
set which is not convex
which is
neither approach you know which is both
well neither approachable nor
but he has this conjecture
of a weaker notion of approachability
which is actually in probability if you
want rather than almost surely
again you want a sequence of fs and x1
xn which comes with two strategies
such that
for all n bigger than or equal to
something that depends on epsilon delta
and s
the distance that's what this is the
distance in x and bar and set
is less than or equal to is bigger than
one minus doubt
but it doesn't say anything about the
point sticking there
right
it's an independent equal it's not a
union
or an intersection
and similarly weak excludability means
with high probability you have to stay
outside instantly
okay and he has his conjecture
that every closed set and closure
doesn't really matter because uh
delta of x s is the same for delta x
that's the delta x bar
um
that in fact every set is
either weakly approachable or weekly
excluded and indeed
that connect conjecture was proved
by manning niklas yay
in 1992
using
differential game theory
and all sorts of fancy stuff
now i think i mentioned to you that that
david pointed to this conjecture when he
suggested that i work on this paper
and uh
so i think there must be an elementary
proof because david
would not give a thesis problem unlike
some of us
unless he basically knew how to do it
so so um
so
i thought i had an elementary group but
i don't uh i think
maybe i'll be able to get one but but
certainly
this was not an elementary tool
and
that's it
[Applause]
are there any questions
right
the algorithm
projecting down to the set of payoffs
yes and that makes it a real line so why
does that argument break down here
oh because because the vector space is
not working
only the line is over
well
but there may be some barriers
i mean i think the idea
of identifying
these sets is nice i think it does
applications
anyway i should have told you by the way
that i am
since i did not follow this line
i
i work
on some of the stuff i've been very
interested in suppression analysis i
know that grocery cart with savage paper
uh red black ball
gertrude
paper
but this is completely new
so
i apologize
i was curious what
famously was very handy information
theory and you said you took information
theory from blackwell and later he
changed his mind it's one way blackboard
had any role
i didn't know
you wrote an article in
yeah i think well first of all i think
blackwell didn't relate to later i mean
he didn't get to information
um
but um
yeah but everything he did i mean
certainly there's information theory
there's something called the bible
channel i believe i know exactly how it
is
but uh
but i think
certainly his thesis
was on markup chats
and
i actually
told somebody
but certainly i had no objection
interesting at all
in fact that course was a bit of an
anomaly in the stats department
uh
should some sense of inventory like
engineering
but
they i think i think
are there other questions
i have a historical question too but i
don't i don't know if it's the right
question i'll ask it anyway
um
i'm wondering if you know what drew him
to look at vector playoffs
in general there was a talk earlier as
well that was i think there was a quote
that he was driven a lot by thinking
about war and fighting the united states
ah yes i remember that i didn't as i
said this is not
i mean i just viewed it as part of this
general
games
but i think uh i think
he
met gershwin he met hershey graham they
certainly worked together right a lot
and and that's what rand was about
who played
games
yeah that's why i was wondering because
it's easy to look now and see how
impactful it's been but it's always easy
to do it
but another example i think of something
like that
i was thinking maybe
talking about
a way of proving
the optimality of
the ratio test
in
a longer transparent
and general way
what was the world happening but about
the same time but which had
it's not at all experienced but
that again it's an idea
i guess dynamic programming is actually
built right
okay
thank you so much peter for a great talk
um well this brings us to the end of uh
today and end of the workshop i think
wants to say a few words about what to
expect
i guess firstly this was amazing like
we
started off planning this and we just
all we did was we kind of identified a
bunch of people and asked them if they
would be willing to talk and
many of the speakers today or several of
the speakers have just come down just
for this day and
like we didn't really say too much about
it it was more you want to do a day in
honor of david blackwell and
it's
like i'm deeply satisfied with how it's
turned out i think we learned a lot from
it's a big round of applause and a big
thanks to all of the speakers
[Applause]
and i guess overall uh this was a fun
boot camp to organize uh and
so
i also want to thank my two amazing
co-organizers uh nika nab and adam who
is somewhere flying back to l.a but
we'll be back next week so let's clap
loudly enough so that he can hear us
[Applause]
and yeah this
sort of gets our semester off to a
really nice start so the plan for the
semester kind of paraphrasing what bin
was talking about we have sorry oh okay
uh we have a lot of
commonality so somehow many of these
ideas have been taken on by a lot of
different communities and taken off in
different directions so we tried getting
people from across many different
communities but hopefully everyone can
come and tell us all the simplest
unknown questions or the simplest open
questions they have and then
in the spirit of blackwell we can also
get together and think deeply about it
uh and we will have a few more workshops
uh so i think the next workshop is being
organized by todoris uh
laura and kevin and this is in three
weeks is that right
so september 12th and roughly speaking
the three workshops that we have are
they're all about sequential decision
making processes but like thinking about
the information structures first then
the constraints and then the objectives
and how all of these have come together
to influence our the way we think about
these processes so i hope to see all of
you all at these workshops and also the
next week we have another program in
parallel on graph limits and there will
be a bootcamp next week so if you're
alarmed tired of talks we have way more
talks
if you can come and attend but on that
note i should stop talking thank you oh
okay i guess tudoris has something else
to say
next monday one day
yes so we'll have a town hall a town
hall to decide what all we should work
on uh next monday you'll get lots of
emails on this uh and slack messages and
all other such forms of communication
but i think for a more for the moment we
should stop and just reflect on all the
things we've heard about today and thank
you everyone for coming in see ya
you